From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. And for this week's program, for Father's Day, everybody on our staff sat around and we talked about what it is that one really wants to hear on Father's Day, or near Father's Day. And Nancy, one of the producers on the show, said, what you really want to hear is parents and kids actually having an honest moment together. Talking about whatever. And so we tried it. We asked this 18-year-old named Chana Wiliford from Waco, Texas, and her father, if they would be willing to have a conversation on tape in which each of them got to ask the other all the questions they had never asked before. And it's interesting what happens when you do that.
这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台和国际公共广播电台联合播出的《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。在本周的节目中，为了迎接父亲节，我们的工作人员聚在一起讨论了人们在父亲节或临近父亲节时最想听到的话。我们节目的制片人之一南希说，人们真正想听的是父母和孩子之间真正坦诚的交流。不论聊什么都好。于是我们尝试了一下。我们请了得克萨斯州韦科市18岁的女孩查娜·威利福德和她的父亲，问他们是否愿意录下一段对话，让他们向对方提出那些以前从未问过的问题。当你这样做时，发生的事情非常有趣。
One of the first things I wanted to start with, Dad, was like when you and mom got together. For example, I know that-- I think, anyway-- you guys met in a bar. And then like two weeks later, you were married.
爸，我想先从一些事情聊起，比如你和妈妈是怎么走到一起的。例如，我知道——或者说我认为——你们是在酒吧认识的。然后大概两周后，你们就结婚了。
Yeah. It was a very short romance.
是啊。那是一段非常短暂的恋情。
You know, what made you guys get married so quickly?
你知道，是什么让你们那么快就结婚的吗？
Yeah, it was kind of a whirlwind thing, you know? I know in my-- from my side of it-- I was looking for somebody. I needed someone in my life. And I guess, you know, she basically was in the same situation. So we both just were looking for somebody, and we ended up hooking up.
嗯，那有点像是一场旋风般的恋情，你知道吧？我知道从我这边来说，我当时在寻找某个人。我的生活中需要一个人。我想，你知道，她当时基本上也处于同样的情况。所以我们都在寻找某个人，然后我们就走到了一起。
Yeah.
是啊。
All through this conversation, Chana goes back and forth between being her father's daughter, his child, and being his peer. And what's so amazing to listen to, is that. That is the end of the long process of parenting. A process that takes decades. The biggest project most of us ever embark upon. This is how you know it all worked out OK, when you can talk to your kid as an equal.
在整个对话过程中，查娜在父亲的女儿、他的孩子和他的同辈人之间来回切换。听着这些真是太令人惊叹了。这就是漫长育儿过程的终点。这是一个历经数十年的过程。这是我们大多数人所着手的最大工程。这就是你怎么知道一切都进展顺利的方式，当你能像平等的人一样与你的孩子交谈时。
Well, what was the family reaction? I know Nana couldn't have been entirely pleased.
那么，家人的反应如何？我知道娜娜不可能完全高兴。
I don't know, you know. I really don't know. You know, I never really asked anybody. Of course, you know, I was in the Marine Corp., and I didn't really care what anybody thought about anything.
我不知道，你知道的。我真的不知道。你知道，我从来没真正问过任何人。当然，你知道，我当时在海军陆战队，我真的不在乎别人对任何事情怎么看。
Well, yeah, you were how-- you were how old? Like 25 at the time, right?
嗯，是的，你当时多大？大概25岁，对吧？
25. Yeah. I was 25. And I had always told myself, you know, that I was going to live hard and party till I got to be 25, and then I was going to get married.
25岁。是的。我当时25岁。我一直告诉自己，你知道，我要在25岁之前过得尽兴、狂欢，然后我就要结婚。
So you stuck with it.
所以你坚持下来了。
Sure enough, that's the way it ended up.
果然，最后就是这样。
Today on our program, what happens when fathers and kids sit down and talk-- actually talk-- and what happens when they don't. It's kind of an amazing little show today. We have four acts. Act One, Pandora's Box, in which Chana and her dad, as we said, ask each other all the unasked questions they've stored up over the years. Act Two, Mack Daddies. In the building in which 18-year-old Sanantonio Brooks lives, in the Chicago public housing projects, most of the fathers are under 25 years old, and they became fathers as teenagers. He talks to some of his friends about whether they are better fathers than their own fathers were. Act Three, Bond, Dammit, Bond, in which a new dad, writer Dan Savage, laments how long it is taking him to truly bond with his baby boy. Act Four, Age of Enchantment. Writer Lawrence Weschler and his eleven-year-old daughter, Sara, tell a true story of parental love, betrayal, fiction, deception, and more love, that happened to the two of them. Stay with us.
今天在我们的节目中，我们将探讨当父亲和孩子坐下来交流——真正的交流——时会发生什么，以及当他们不交流时会发生什么。今天这真是一场精彩的节目。我们有四个部分。第一部分，潘多拉魔盒，正如我们所说，查娜和她父亲问对方那些多年来一直没问过的问题。第二部分，超级老爸。在圣安东尼奥·布鲁克斯居住的芝加哥公共住房大楼里，大多数父亲都在25岁以下，他们在十几岁时就当了父亲。他与一些朋友讨论他们是否比自己的父亲做得更好。第三部分，联结，该死的联结，新晋父亲、作家丹·萨维奇感叹他需要多长时间才能真正与他的男婴建立联系。第四部分，魔法时代。作家劳伦斯·韦施勒和他11岁的女儿萨拉讲述了一个关于父爱、背叛、虚构、欺骗以及更多爱的真实故事，这是他们两人之间发生的事情。请继续收听。
Act One, Pandora's Box. So I already explained the premise for Chana's taped conversation with her dad. A few quick words about them before we start. Chana grew up in Waco. But unlike most of the people who she knows there, Chana left Texas, went to college in Philadelphia, where she just finished her freshman year at Temple. Her dad works at the phone company installing big switching systems, stuff like that. He and her mom have been married and divorced and remarried to each other three times.
第一部分，潘多拉魔盒。所以我已经解释了查娜与她父亲录制对话的前提。在我们开始之前，先简单介绍一下他们。查娜在韦科长大。但与她认识的大多数人不同，查娜离开了得克萨斯，去费城上大学，她刚刚在天普大学完成了大一学业。她父亲在电话公司工作，安装大型交换系统之类的设备。他和她妈妈结过婚，离过婚，又复婚，一共三次。
One of my original questions, when first asked to interview you, basically was-- the first thing that just popped into my head, that I've never asked, that every kid wants to know, is where was I conceived?
我最初被要求采访你时，脑子里蹦出的第一个问题，也是我从未问过、每个孩子都想知道的问题，就是我是在哪里受孕的？
Where were you conceived?
你在哪里受孕的？
If you even remember.
如果你还记得的话。
Yeah, I think I remember. If I remember correct, I believe it was out at Lake Athens.
嗯，我想我记得。如果我没记错的话，我相信是在阿森斯湖边。
Lake Athens.
阿森斯湖。
Yeah. It was late, you know, one or two in the morning, whatever. And I [UNINTELLIGIBLE] in that old maroon pickup truck, if you remember that. I had like a blanket or something because we ended up in the bed of the truck. And that's--
是的。那是在深夜，你知道，凌晨一两点之类的。如果记得的话，当时我在那辆老式的褐红色皮卡车里。我好像带了条毯子，因为我们最后待在卡车斗里。就是那样……
Maybe that was the wrong question to ask.
也许这问错问题了。
Well--
嗯……
And as far as, like, me growing up, and things like that, you know, just-- I don't know. You know, going which way I want to go now. How has that been for you to watch me? You know, kind of like not be like everybody else where I grew up?
关于我成长的过程之类的事情，你知道，我不知道。我现在选择了自己想走的路。看着我这样，对你来说感觉如何？你知道，有点不像我长大的地方的其他人那样？
Well, truthfully, I'm glad. You know? And there's some of it, you know, that has scared me. I mean, just the fact that you're in Philadelphia still scares me. Because I worry about you, and I worry about, you know--
说实话，我很高兴。你知道吗？而且其中有些部分，你知道，也让我感到害怕。我的意思是，仅仅是你还在费城这一点就让我害怕。因为我担心你，我担心，你知道……
Well, of course.
嗯，当然。
--something happening to you, and all that kind of stuff. But I don't know. I enjoy watching you, you know? I mean, it's-- I don't know. There's nothing in this world that's ever pleased me more than you. You're great, you know? I just can't tell you. I just couldn't be prouder.
……发生在你身上的事情，诸如此类。但我不知道。我喜欢看着你，你知道吗？我的意思是……我不知道。这世上没什么比你更让我高兴的了。你很棒，你知道吗？我简直无法形容。我为你感到无比骄傲。
Well, kind of back to the history thing. You know, of course, you guys got divorced last May, I guess. I don't even really remember. And then you got remarried in what? December?
那么，回到历史问题。你知道，当然，我想你们去年五月离婚了。我甚至记不清了。然后你们又结婚了，是在什么时候？十二月吗？
Yeah, I believe that's right.
是的，我想是那样。
Yeah, I think. So that's got to seem a little strange to every-- well, to yourself, too, I'm sure. But it definitely seems strange to everyone around you. I can assure that.
嗯，我想是吧。这对每个人——嗯，我相信对你自己也是——来说一定显得有点奇怪。但我可以肯定，这对你身边的每个人来说绝对显得很奇怪。
Well, it is. It definitely is. And even to me, you know? I don't know how else to look at it, Chana. I've thought about it over and over and over. All's I know is I love her. And I can't live with her and I can't live without her. You know, that old saying. I don't know. I'm just not sure. You know, what the problem is or what the-- even myself, I can't figure it out. At this point, I can't swear it won't happen again. If it does, it's not going to be my fault.
嗯，确实如此。绝对是。甚至对我来说也是，你知道吗？我不知道该怎么看这件事，查娜。我一遍又一遍地想过这个问题。我只知道我爱她。我无法和她生活在一起，但没有她我又活不下去。你知道，那句老话。我不知道。我只是不确定。你知道，问题出在哪里，或者……我自己也搞不清楚。此时此刻，我不敢保证这种事不会再发生。如果真的发生了，那不会是我的错。
Well, do you think that the last time was your fault?
那么，你认为上次是你的错吗？
Yeah, I guess, in a way it was. Because, you know, I got in trouble again. My drinking thing. And I don't know that the divorce was actually my fault. Because I told her, we should just slow down and get a look at the big picture, it's not that bad. But she was determined to make her point. And so she did what she did. She filed for divorce. We did the divorce. And then I guess she did realize it wasn't that bad. And so we ended up getting back together.
是的，我想，在某种程度上是。因为，你知道，我又惹麻烦了。我的酗酒问题。我不认为离婚真的是我的错。因为我告诉过她，我们应该放慢节奏，看看大局，情况没那么糟。但她决心要坚持她的观点。所以她做了她做的事。她申请了离婚。我们离婚了。然后我想她确实意识到情况没那么糟。所以我们最后又复合了。
Well, you know, on my end of the deal, I was just kind of confused, you know? I don't know. I think I was, not happy, but more relieved, at the fact that you guys were splitting up. Just because of all the problems that I've seen over the years. And then it just kind of-- I don't know. I was disappointed. Maybe just with the situation in general, kind of with you.
嗯，你知道，站在我的立场上，我只是感到困惑，你知道吗？我不知道。我想我当时并不是高兴，更多的是感到释然，因为你们分开了。仅仅是因为我多年来看到的那些问题。然后就那样……我不知道。我很失望。也许只是对整体的情况，还有对你，感到失望。
Yeah, I know you were. But I've got to be happy, too. Or at least whatever I think's happy.
是的，我知道你很失望。但我得寻找快乐，也。或者至少是我认为的快乐。
Well, I'm not going to say I didn't want you to be happy. But you know, I kind of thought that maybe you could finally find your happiness somewhere else. You know what I mean?
嗯，我不会说我不希望你快乐。但你知道，我当时觉得也许你最终能在别处找到你的幸福。你知道我的意思吗？
Yeah, but I don't know that-- that wasn't working out. I just couldn't-- I don't know. It's weird, you know, when you're married for that long to be not married. And I really didn't know what to do. I didn't know how to go about it. And I feel a lot more comfortable, even if I'm not totally happy, I feel safe when I'm married, you know what I mean? And, you know, it always goes back to the fact that I love the girl. I don't know what else.
是的，但我不知道……那样行不通。我就是不能……我不知道。这很奇怪，你知道，当你结婚那么久却突然没结婚了。我真的不知道该怎么办。我不知道怎么处理。即使我并不完全快乐，我觉得在婚姻中我感到更舒服、更安全，你知道我的意思吗？而且，你知道，这总是回到我爱那个女孩这一事实上。我不知道还能怎样。
I don't know. I just worry about you, you know what I mean?
我不知道。我只是担心你，你知道我的意思吗？
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah. I want to make sure that you're happy, for the most part.
是的。我大部分时间都想确保你快乐。
Oh, I'm going to get happy. You know, I mean, one way or the other, I'm going to get happy. I've got the biggest thing there is, right there in you. And Wes, and Leah, and these grandkids, you know? That's my reward in life. Y'all are. You know? Y'all are it. That's what dads do. That's what I do, anyway.
哦，我会快乐起来的。你知道，我的意思是，无论如何，我会快乐起来的。我拥有世上最宝贵的东西，就是你。还有韦斯、莉亚，以及这些孙辈们，你知道吗？那是我的生活奖励。你们就是。你知道吗？你们就是一切。这就是父亲该做的。无论如何，这就是我做的。
Bob Wiliford and his daughter, Chana. When it came time for him to ask his questions of her during their interview, there was this little technical problem in the taping. Maybe you noticed the buzzing all through their interview on the tape. Anyway, his voice was only recorded over the phone line to the studio where Chana was sitting in Philadelphia. And he basically just had one question for Chana.
鲍勃·威利福德和他的女儿查娜。当采访中轮到他问她问题时，录音出现了一个小技术故障。也许你注意到了采访录音中一直存在的嗡嗡声。总之，他的声音只是通过电话线录制到了查娜在费城所在的演播室。他基本上只问了查娜一个问题。
Of course, you know, a dad's-- one of dad's main concerns is your love life. Your situation with sex and how that situation is-- I don't know how to put it-- coming along, I guess. Is it a problem or are you just handling it?
当然，你知道，父亲的主要关切之一就是你的爱情生活。你关于性的情况，以及那个情况是……我不知道该怎么表达……进展得如何，我想。这是一个问题吗，还是你只是在处理它？
No, it's not a problem. Of course, I'm sure you can just kind of--
不，这不是一个问题。当然，我相信你大概可以……
My major concern is you're being safe.
我主要关心的是你要注意安全。
Yeah. Well, definitely.
是的。嗯，当然。
Act Two, Mack Daddies. Sanantonio Brooks is 18, lives in the public housing projects here in Chicago. 4120 South Prairie.
第二部分，超级老爸。圣安东尼奥·布鲁克斯18岁，住在这里的芝加哥公共住房项目中。草原南路4120号。
There's a lot of young fathers in the building. So they don't really celebrate Father's Day like other people celebrate Father's Day, because they're young fathers. Like, what happened last year? I know a lot of fathers got together. They got a lot of beer. They smoke weed, so they all gathered around in one room, and they was just sitting there chilling. Just talked about, you know what I'm saying, things that they did in their childhood. Like that, what was going on around the building in the day, what they going to be doing all later in the future, and stuff like that.
大楼里有很多年轻父亲。所以他们不像其他人那样庆祝父亲节，因为他们是年轻的父亲。比如，去年发生了什么？我知道很多父亲聚在了一起。他们买了很多啤酒。他们抽大麻，所以大家都聚在一个房间里，只是坐在那里放松。谈论着，你知道我在说什么，他们童年时期做过的事情。就像那样，白天大楼里发生了什么，他们未来打算做什么，诸如此类的事情。
This is a part of our program about dads who have not gotten quite so close with their own children. Two thirds of African-American children are raised in single parent families, usually by their mothers or grandmothers. Sanantonio did a story for our program a year ago. And when Father's Day was coming up this year, he told us that he'd like to interview some of the young fathers in his building. Guys his age and just a little older. Guys he's known since he was a kid. He wanted to talk to them about their relationships with their kids and their relationship with their own fathers. Some guys, hearing this, tried to avoid him.
这是我们关于那些与自己孩子并不亲近的父亲的节目的一部分。三分之二的非裔美国儿童在单亲家庭中长大，通常由母亲或祖母抚养。圣安东尼奥一年前为我们的节目做过一个报道。当今年父亲节临近时，他告诉我们他想采访大楼里的一些年轻父亲。和他年纪相仿或者稍大一点的人。他从童年时期就认识的人。他想和他们谈谈他们与孩子的关系，以及他们与自己父亲的关系。有些人听到这个，试图躲避他。
Some people did more than avoid. They literally dodged me.
有些人做的不仅仅是躲避。他们简直是在回避我。
And why do you think that is?
你认为为什么会这样？
I can't say for sure. It was like, a lot of them just didn't want to really be interviewed about Father's Day.
我无法确定。感觉就像，他们中的许多人真的不想就父亲节接受采访。
Hold up [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
等一下……
You ain't got to give your name.
你不需要提供你的名字。
A lot of people, they didn't want the environment that I have for them. So I had to catch them at their time.
很多人，他们不想在我给他们的那种环境下进行。所以我必须在他们有空的时候抓住他们。
OK.
好的。
What did you think when you first found out that you was having kids?
当你第一次发现你要有孩子时，你是怎么想的？
First I wanted to go crazy. Then at first-- then after that, when I seen them coming into the world, I changed. I enjoyed it.
起初我想发疯。然后起初……在那之后，当我看到他们来到这个世界时，我变了。我享受它。
You enjoyed it?
你享受它？
Mm-hmm. You know how people, when they young and they ain't got no kids, they want to party all the time. Pfft. When you get kids, partying stops. The money-- the little money you do have, got to go towards them kids. Kids deserve everything you can possibly give them. Love, everything.
嗯哼。你知道人们在年轻、没孩子的时候，总是想狂欢。嘿。当你有了孩子，狂欢就停止了。钱——你那仅有的一点钱，必须花在那些孩子身上。孩子们理应得到你所能给予的一切。爱，一切。
How often do you see your kids?
你多久见一次你的孩子？
Every weekend.
每个周末。
How often do you buy your kids something?
你多久给你的孩子买一次东西？
Whenever I get some money.
只要我一有钱就买。
Some of them, they straight with their kids, they take care of their kids. Then the other ones, they-- they don't even-- it's like they claim their kids but they don't do nothing for them. It's like they play the father role every now and then.
他们中的一些人，对自己的孩子很负责，照顾他们的孩子。然后另外一些人，他们……他们甚至……就像他们声称是孩子的父亲，但他们什么也不为孩子做。就像他们偶尔扮演一下父亲的角色。
Do they give money to the mom?
他们给孩子的母亲钱吗？
Nuh-uh. It depends. Now, because most of them, they not working. So they downstairs, serving drugs or whatever. And many times-- mostly they ain't making too much money, you know what I'm saying? To take care of themselves. So most of them ain't really looking out for their kids.
没有。这取决于情况。因为他们大多数人没有工作。所以他们在楼下兜售毒品之类的。而且很多时候——大部分时候他们挣不到太多钱，你知道我在说什么吗？能照顾好他们自己就不错了。所以他们中的大多数人并没有真正照顾他们的孩子。
Yeah, you should probably explain that. I think most people around the country, when they think of people selling drugs, they think of what they've seen in the movies and that they're making a ton of money.
是的，你应该解释一下。我想全国大多数人在想到贩毒的人时，会想到他们在电影里看到的那样，以为他们赚了很多钱。
Nope, not all of them. Most of them's just down [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. And when they be down there, they just make-- barely make enough to eat from day to day. Just down there hustling.
不，并非所有人。他们大多数人只是在楼下……当你在那楼下时，他们赚的钱勉强够维持每天的伙食。只是在那里为了生活打拼。
So you talked to those five guys, and what did most of them feel about their fathers?
所以你采访了那五个人，他们中大多数人对自己父亲的看法是什么？
Most of them, I'd say, they had feelings for their fathers, but it wasn't too deep. Because they felt that their father was not around. So they really had a lot of regrets and then a lot of hostility built up inside.
大多数人，我想说，他们对自己的父亲有感情，但不是很深。因为他们觉得自己的父亲不在身边。所以他们确实积累了很多遗憾和很多内心深处的敌意。
Was your father around when you were coming up?
你成长过程中你父亲在身边吗？
No, he wasn't. My father was gone. Just put it like that, you know what I'm saying. Bad childhood. So I didn't basically see my father but maybe three times in my life.
不，他不在。我父亲走了。就这么说吧，你知道我在说什么。糟糕的童年。所以我一生中大概只见过我父亲三次。
So how did you feel about that?
所以你是怎么想的？
Actually, you want to know the truth? I'm a devil in disguise. So it's like I had to see it in person, see him in person, for me to react on that. But at the same time, my feelings now, I'd probably kill him.
其实，你想听实话吗？我是伪装的恶魔。所以我必须亲眼见到他，亲眼见到他，我才能对此作出反应。但与此同时，我现在的心情是，我可能会杀了他。
Everybody I grew up with, it's like their fathers either left at an early age or they passed away, or something like that. Basically, their fathers dropped in and out of their lives just like mine did.
我一起长大的每个人，他们的父亲要么在很小的时候就离开了，要么去世了，或者诸如此类。基本上，他们的父亲就像我的一样，在他们的生活中若隐若现。
The thing I was going to ask is, I mean, you know, their fathers drop in and out of their lives, but now they're doing that to their kids.
我想问的是，我的意思是，你知道，他们的父亲在他们的生活中若隐若现，但现在他们也这样对待自己的孩子。
Right. It's a cycle that-- everybody in our building, they-- they pay-- I see it. They pass it on from generation to generation. It just stays in the building. It's like, they don't know how to take those steps to change it.
对。这是一个循环……每个人在我们大楼里，他们……我看到了。他们代代相传。它就留在大楼里。就像他们不知道如何采取那些步骤来改变它。
How do you feel about your father?
你对自己父亲的感受如何？
I can't explain. My father left and he hasn't been back since.
我无法解释。我父亲走了，从那以后就再没回来过。
What do you think your kids are going to think of you?
你认为你的孩子会怎么看你？
My kid sees me and my kid smiles all the time, every time my kid sees me.
我的孩子见到我总是会笑，每次我的孩子见到我时。
Would you say you played a positive role in your child's life?
你会说你在孩子的生活中扮演了积极的角色吗？
Yes.
是的。
Are there any father figures in your life left?
你生活中还有任何父亲形象吗？
No.
没有。
What did you think when you first heard you were going to have a baby?
当你第一次听说你要有孩子时，你是怎么想的？
Man, it was wow. But at the same time, I was bogus. Because I could have been there when he was born. I ain't going to trip though.
天呐，真棒。但与此同时，我也感到很糟。因为我本可以在他出生时就在那里。但我不想纠结这些。
How often would you say that you see your kid?
你会说你多久见一次你的孩子？
When I get a chance. I got to say that. When I get a chance. But at the same time, I know you're well taken care of.
当我有机会的时候。我必须这么说。当我有机会的时候。但与此同时，我知道你被照顾得很好。
How often do you buy your son something?
你多久给你的儿子买一次东西？
As often as I can. That's the same-- that's just like asking the same question. I can't buy him nothing unless I'm around him. I'm going to ship it in the mail? I'm not rolling like that. So when I get a chance to, that's when I do what I can. Because the little things I do do, at least I did it. And I can't say nobody made me do this, because my father wasn't there for me, when I was growing up. So therefore, the little things I do, I do appreciate, and he do-- Jeremy do too.
只要我能的时候。那是一样……那就像问同样的问题。除非我在他身边，否则我什么也买不了。我要用邮寄的吗？我不玩那种把戏。所以当我有机会的时候，我就尽我所能。因为我做的那些小事，至少我做了。而且我不能说没人逼我这样做，因为我成长时，我的父亲不在我身边。所以因此，我做的小事，我都很珍惜，他也一样——杰里米也是。
How do you feel as a father?
你作为父亲感觉如何？
I feel great.
我觉得很棒。
What do you think your kids are going to think of you?
你认为你的孩子会怎么看你？
Daddy did the best that he can. And he's going to keep on doing the best he can.
爸爸尽了他最大的努力。而且他会继续尽他所能。
It's interesting, because most of the guys you talked to felt like-- even though most them only would see their kids like once a week, or maybe twice a week-- they all felt like they were doing a decent job, or doing a better job than their fathers did. What do you think of that?
这很有趣，因为你交谈的大多数人都觉得——即使他们大多数人可能一周只见孩子一次或两次——他们都觉得自己在做一份不错的工作，或者比他们的父亲做得更好。你对此怎么看？
I think, compared to how their fathers treat them, I feel that they're doing pretty good for themselves if they're seeing them two times a week, if they only seen their father once, twice a year.
我认为，与他们父亲对待他们的方式相比，我觉得如果他们一周见孩子两次，而他们自己一年只见过父亲一两次，他们对自己做得相当不错。
In a way, it just goes to show you just how far things have gone. That once or twice a week would seem like a lot.
从某种程度上讲，这恰恰说明了事情发展到什么地步了。一周一两次似乎已经很多了。
Yes. Well, to them it does seem like a lot because-- it's hard to explain. In my situation, if my father came to see me two or three times in a week, I think it would have made a difference. So I think, basically, they're making a difference in their kids life.
是的。嗯，对他们来说，确实似乎很多，因为……很难解释。在我的情况下，如果我父亲一周来看我两三次，我想这会产生不同的结果。所以我认为，基本上，他们正在改变孩子的生活。
How often have you seen your father?
你见过你父亲多少次？
How often do I see my father? I seen my father-- the last time I seen him-- it's been, I'd say, three years ago. Then before that, it'd been at least two. So he'll pop in like every two, three years.
我见过我父亲多少次？我上次见我父亲——已经有三年了。在那之前，至少有两年。所以他会每两三年冒出来一次。
What kind of difference would it make if you saw him two or three times a week?
如果你一周见他两三次，会有什么不同吗？
It probably would have made a lot of difference. I know I probably wouldn't have growed up the way I growed up now. There's just a lot of things, but I really can't say for sure.
那可能会有很大的不同。我知道我可能不会像我现在这样长大。有很多事情，但我真的不能确定。
What do you think your kids are going to grow up thinking of you?
你认为你的孩子长大后会怎么看你？
Well, my son often tell me I'm a surv-- daddy, you're a survivor, ain't you? Yeah, I'm a survivor. Because I've been out here too long. You know what I'm saying? I don't want to work, do things like that. So only thing they basically can say is I was out here bogus, but I also was a survivor. I did what I could for him, as well as for anybody else. But I basically had to live for myself. Because that's all I got, actually is self.
嗯，我儿子经常告诉我我是一个生还者——爸爸，你是个生还者，对吧？是的，我是一个生还者。因为我在外面混得太久了。你知道我在说什么吗？我不想工作，做那种事情。所以他们基本上只能说我是一个混蛋，但我也曾是一个生还者。我尽我所能为他以及其他人做了事。但我基本上必须为自己而活。因为我实际拥有的只有自己。
You know, it's interesting when you talk about your father. You don't sound angry. You sound more sad than angry.
你知道，当你谈论你父亲时很有意思。你听起来并不愤怒。你听起来更多是悲伤而不是愤怒。
It is, like, you really can't be angry with them because you know them. And then you still love then. But you're disappointed in the way that he left you. And in some ways, you probably know why he left, but then you want to get the understanding out of his mouth, why he left. And that's something that, my father, he hasn't done yet. I asked him-- he knows I know why he left, but he-- it's like he won't explain why he can't come into my life now, even though I'm getting older. So, it's still-- I'm upset, and then in a way I'm mad, but mostly upset. Because right about now, I feel that if he really wanted to be in my life, he would've-- it's coming down to graduation. He would have asked me, was I graduating? What it is I'm doing? He ain't even call for that. So I'm not letting none of that bother me or worry me.
是啊，因为你真的不能对他们生气，因为你了解他们。然后你仍然爱他们。但你对他离开你的方式感到失望。从某种程度上说，你可能知道他为什么要离开，但你还是想从他口中得到解释，为什么他离开了。而那是我的父亲还没做到的事情。我问过他——他知道我知道他为什么要离开，但他——感觉他不会解释为什么他现在不能进入我的生活，即使我正在长大。所以，这仍然——我很沮丧，从某种程度上我很生气，但更多的是沮丧。因为现在看来，我觉得如果他真的想进入我的生活，他会的——快要毕业了。他会问我，我要毕业了吗？我在做什么？他甚至没有打电话问这些。所以我不会让这些烦扰或困扰我。
You're graduating like this week?
你这周就要毕业了？
Yes.
是的。
So for you to call him, it's like-- it's a matter of pride.
所以对你来说给他打电话，就像是一个尊严的问题。
Yeah. As a matter of fact, that's what it is. Because I feel that if I make-- if I call up there-- for me, it will seem like I'm making the first move. And I feel I shouldn't have to. Because that's my father and I'm the kid. You know what I'm saying? Like he won't reach out to me, so why should I reach out to somebody that doesn't want to reach out to me?
是的。事实上，这就是原因。因为我觉得如果我……如果我打那个电话——对我来说，那看起来就像是我在迈出第一步。我觉得我不应该这样做。因为那是我的父亲，我是孩子。你知道我在说什么吗？就像他不会主动联系我，那我为什么要联系一个不想联系我的人呢？
Do you think these guys just forget how it feels?
你认为这些人只是忘记了那种感觉吗？
Probably.
可能吧。
You see, I had to see myself as a daddy. A father is one who is able to take care of their child. I'm not there yet. So I don't recognize myself as a father.
你看，我必须把自己看作一个爸爸。父亲是能够照顾自己孩子的人。我还没达到那个水平。所以我还没把自己认作一个父亲。
Since that interview and that story, Sanantonio Brooks graduated from high school here in Chicago. His father wasn't there.
自从那次采访和报道之后，圣安东尼奥·布鲁克斯从芝加哥的一所高中毕业了。他的父亲没去。
[MUSIC - "DADDY'S HOME" BY SHEP & THE LIMELIGHTS]
[音乐 - 谢普与星光组合演唱的《爸爸回家了》]
Act Three, Bond, Dammit, Bond. Now another case study of a dad who is waiting to feel closer to his kid. Dan Savage has done a number of stories for our program. He writes the syndicated sex advice column, Savage Love. He and his boyfriend Terry spent months and months trying to adopt, and finally did adopt a baby boy just recently, from a teenage mom named Jessica. And now Dan is waiting to feel like the dad that he wants to be.
第三部分，联结，该死的联结。现在是另一个关于正在等待与孩子更亲近的父亲的案例研究。丹·萨维奇为我们的节目做过很多报道。他撰写联合刊出的性建议专栏《萨维奇之爱》。他和他的男友特里花了几个月的时间试图领养，最近终于从一位名叫杰西卡的年轻妈妈那里领养了一个男婴。现在丹正在等待感受他想要成为的那种父亲。
When I first held the baby, 20 minutes after he was born, I was surprised that I didn't feel an instantaneous rush of anything. The baby was doing his part. He was tiny, he was cute, his eyes were open. But I couldn't hold up my end of the deal, the dad end. When I looked at him, no instant this-is-my-son bonding took place. Bond, I said to myself. Bond, dammit, bond. What was wrong with me? Why was I having to will myself to feel something I assumed would happen on its own, like magic? I had to bond. In two days, my boyfriend Terry and I would be taking this baby home. We were going to be dads.
当我第一次抱着这个孩子，在他出生20分钟后，我感到惊讶的是，我并没有感到任何瞬间的冲动。孩子在做他自己的事。他很小，很可爱，眼睛睁开了。但我没能履行合同的另一端，即父亲的那一端。当我看着他时，并没有产生那种瞬间的“这是我的儿子”的联结感。联结，我对自己说。联结，该死的，联结。我怎么了？为什么我必须强迫自己去感受一些我以为会自动发生的事情，就像魔法一样？我必须建立联结。两天后，我的男友特里和我就要带这个孩子回家了。我们将成为父亲。
This moment has been coming for two years. We'd been to seminars, read stacks of books, written stacks of progressively larger checks. Had social workers tramping in and out of our house, and opened our bank accounts, police records, and skulls for inspection by the adoption agency. We'd been talking about this moment, the moment we would become dads, for a long time. For so long, in fact, that it had come to seem like just so much talk, one big abstraction. Maybe I was just a little numb when the baby was finally handed to me.
这一刻已经酝酿了两年。我们参加过研讨会，读过成堆的书，写过一张张越来越大的支票。有社会工作者进进出出我们的房子，打开了我们的银行账户、犯罪记录，以及头颅，供领养机构检查。我们谈论这一刻，即我们成为父亲的那一刻，已经很久了。实际上太久了，以至于它看起来就像仅仅是空谈，一个巨大的抽象概念。也许当孩子终于被交到我手中时，我只是有点麻木。
Later that night, the four of us-- me, Terry, Jessica, and the baby-- were hanging out in Jessica's room. I had the honor of changing the first poopy diaper, filled with what looked like Hershey's syrup. And pretty soon I was starting to feel something. Not quite a dad feeling yet, but something more than babysitter. But the feelings were tenuous and I didn't focus on them for fear of squelching them. Terry, on the other hand, says there was nothing tenuous about his feelings, even right from the start.
那天晚上晚些时候，我们四个人——我、特里、杰西卡和孩子——待在杰西卡的房间里。我有幸换了第一个大便的尿布，里面看起来像是好时糖浆。很快我开始感觉到一些东西。还不是那种父亲的感觉，但不仅仅是保姆的感觉。但这些感觉很脆弱，我不敢集中注意力去细想，怕它们消失。另一方面，特里说，他的感觉一点也不脆弱，甚至从一开始就是如此。
So when did you first feel a bond?
那么你第一次感受到联结是什么时候？
When we went up to the birthing suites at the hospital, you know, hours after he was born. And watched him get all his reflex exams and his first bath. It was like, you know, I felt attached to him. I felt like watching him every moment because this was our-- this was it. This was the one. You know, he was so pretty and he was so beautiful. He was just this like perfect little baby boy that had been put in our lives. You want to hear the horsey song? Giddyup, giddyup, giddyup--
当我们走进医院的分娩套房时，你知道，在他出生几小时后。看着他接受所有的反射检查和第一次洗澡。这就像是，你知道，我感觉和他联结在一起了。我感觉每一刻都在注视着他，因为这是我们的——就是这个。就是这个。你知道，他太可爱了，太漂亮了。他就是那个被放进我们生活中的完美小男婴。你想听骑马歌吗？驾，驾，驾……
Here's how bonded Terry is to the baby. He's made up a burping song so involved that it not only has two choruses, but a bridge and a key change.
这就是特里和孩子联结的程度。他自创了一首拍嗝歌，内容非常复杂，不仅有两个副歌，还有一个桥段和一个转调。
We love you so when you ride out yonder on our little knee. We love you so when you ride out yonder and you go bleh, whee. Little boy, little boy, little boy, DJ. Little boy, little boy, little boy, horsey. Little boy, little boy, little boy, little boy.
我们如此爱你，当你在我们的膝盖上骑行。我们如此爱你，当你在我们的膝盖上骑行，然后你发出咯咯声，喔。小男孩，小男孩，小男孩，DJ。小男孩，小男孩，小男孩，小马。小男孩，小男孩，小男孩，小男孩。
Did you write that yourself?
那是你自己写的吗？
I did. That's an original.
是的。那是原创的。
With most biological parents, the bond is instantaneous. Baby books reassure biological parents who don't feel an instant bond not to worry, the bond will come. So there must be some who don't feel it right away. But doing an adoption, we had some options. And when and how to bond, when to decide that we were officially fathers, was among them. Driving to the hospital that day, we knew we could walk away from this baby at any point and for any reason before we signed the placement papers. Club feet, cleft palate, bad hair, we wouldn't have to give a reason. We didn't talk about it, but this was rattling around in some corner of our brains.
对于大多数亲生父母来说，联结是瞬间的。育儿书安慰那些没有感觉到即时联结的亲生父母不要担心，联结会来的。所以肯定有一些人没有立刻感受到它。但在领养过程中，我们有一些选择。何时以及如何联结，何时决定我们正式成为父亲，都在其中。那天开车去医院时，我们知道在签署安置文件之前，我们可以随时以任何理由放弃这个孩子。内翻足、腭裂、头发不好，我们甚至不需要给出一个理由。我们没谈论它，但这在我们的脑海深处盘旋。
It's taboo in some adoption circles to acknowledge these things. We're supposed to toe the line and say that adopting a baby is just like having one of our own. That our feelings for the baby, from the moment we first laid eyes on him, were no different than if the kid had been our own biological child. But it is different, fundamentally different.
在一些领养圈子里，承认这些事情是禁忌。我们应该循规蹈矩，说领养一个孩子就像拥有我们自己的孩子一样。我们对这个孩子的感情，从我们第一眼看到他开始，就和这个孩子是我们亲生的没有任何不同。但它是不同的，从根本上是不同的。
Perhaps I should stop here and acknowledge something that some of you may be thinking as you sit listening to me talk. For some of you, I am your worst nightmare. A homosexual sex writer and sometime drag queen, who, with his boy-toy boyfriend, has adopted a vulnerable little baby boy. You fear we intend to put him in leather diapers, hang a mirrored ball over his crib, teach him to dance to YMCA, and slowly draw him into our perverted lifestyle. Or maybe you think worse.
也许我应该在这里停下来，承认一些你们在听我说话时可能正在想的事情。对你们中的一些人来说，我是你们最可怕的噩梦。一个同性恋性专栏作家，偶尔的变装皇后，与他的男孩玩具男友一起，领养了一个脆弱的小男婴。你们担心我们打算给他穿上皮革尿布，在他的婴儿床上方挂一个镜面球，教他随着《YMCA》跳舞，并慢慢将他引入我们那变态的生活方式。或者也许你们想得更糟。
When we were still doing our paperwork, straight friends would ask if I was excited about becoming a dad. I would say, yes, Terry's gotten so loose. And this I know is the fear. The fear that's led two states to outlaw gay men and lesbians adopting children, and made it nearly impossible in most other states, even if it is technically legal. Yet if I wanted to have sex with children, which I don't, there are easier, less expensive, and less emotionally taxing ways to arrange for that. I could join the priesthood or coach Little League or-- well, I'm going to stop taking these cheap shots in the spirit of being a role model. I am a dad now, you know? At least officially.
当我们还在处理文书工作时，异性恋朋友会问我是否对成为父亲感到兴奋。我会说，是的，特里变得如此松弛。而这我知道就是恐惧。这种恐惧导致两个州取缔了男同性恋者和女同性恋者领养孩子，并使这在大多数其他州几乎变得不可能，即使在技术上是合法的。然而，如果我想和孩子发生性关系，而我并不想，那么有更容易、更便宜且在情感上负担更小的方法来实现这一点。我可以加入教会或教少棒联盟或——好吧，出于做一个榜样的精神，我不再采取这些廉价的手段了。我现在是一位父亲，你知道吗？至少在官方层面上。
What's funny about the whole evil, disco dancin', gay, baby-raping nightmare is that the truth of why gay men want to be dads is actually so much more disturbing. When I fantasized about becoming a dad, I didn't picture myself having sex with my children. And even now, though I don't quite feel like a dad yet, I'd cut the heart out of anyone who so much as laid an ill-intentioned finger on our kid. No, in my dad fantasies, I saw myself going to work, making money, coming home to Terry and the kid. I'd help with the homework, take the kid to ball games, McDonald's, and camping. My dad fantasies are straight-- straight out of the '50s-- with Terry staying at home and taking care of the kid. Just like a '50s mom.
关于整个邪恶、跳迪斯科、同性恋、强奸婴儿的噩梦，有趣的是，同性恋者想要成为父亲的真实原因实际上要让人不安得多。当我想象成为父亲时，我没有把自己想象成与我的孩子发生性关系。即使现在，虽然我还不完全感觉像个父亲，但如果有人哪怕对我们的孩子动一根恶意的手指，我也会挖出那个人的心脏。不，在我的父亲幻想中，我看到自己去工作、赚钱，回家找特里和孩子。我会帮他做作业，带孩子去看球赛、吃麦当劳和露营。我的父亲幻想是直的——直接出自50年代——特里待在家里照顾孩子。就像一个50年代的妈妈。
I do see that. And I don't mind it. I love staying home with him. He's so wonderful. He's so great. And he's so much fun to stay home with and play with and watch smile all day. And now that he's beginning to coo and make all sorts of funny sounds, it's just great.
我确实看到了。而且我不介意。我喜欢待在家里陪他。他太棒了。他太伟大了。而且待在家里陪他玩、看着他整天微笑真是太有趣了。现在他开始发出咯咯声并发出各种有趣的声音，这真是太好了。
People ask Terry how it's different to have the baby and he answers, now I have two people to pick up after. That's our family. I go out and make the donuts. Terry stays at home and picks up after us. We're taping every episode of the Teletubbies. We don't have sex anymore. We're typical American parents. When Terry imagines what it'll be like when the kid is five, he sounds an awful lot like June Cleaver.
人们问特里养这个孩子有什么不同，他回答说，现在我有两个人要收拾了。这就是我们的家庭。我出去挣甜甜圈。特里待在家里收拾我们的残局。我们正在录制每一集《天线宝宝》。我们不再有性生活了。我们是典型的美国父母。当特里想象孩子五岁时会是什么样子，他听起来非常像琼·克利弗。
Making cookies and going to PTA meetings and volunteering for being a chaperone, going to the zoo. Being a kindergarten volunteer. Helping kids cut and paste and keep things out of their mouths.
做饼干、参加PTA会议、志愿当监护人、去动物园。做幼儿园志愿者。帮助孩子剪纸、粘贴，防止他们把东西放进嘴里。
But Terry doesn't see this as being the mom. This is being a dad like his dad was.
但特里并不认为这是在做妈妈。这是像他父亲那样做父亲。
Well, in my family, I mean, my dad did everything. My dad cooked, he cleaned. He made pies in the summer. He built houses. He reroofed garages. But he also helped with homework. And I feel like I'm doing the same amount of work my father would have done. I kind of feel like I'm sort of following in the footsteps of my own father.
嗯，在我的家庭里，我的父亲做了所有事。我父亲做饭、打扫。他在夏天做馅饼。他盖房子。他给车库重新铺屋顶。但他也会帮忙做作业。我觉得我在做我父亲会做的一样多的工作。我有点觉得自己像是在追随我父亲的足迹。
Terry's following the footsteps of his father and I'm following in the footsteps of mine. Not completely connected to the kid, not around as much, sometimes leaving before he wakes up in the morning and getting home after he is already asleep at night. Doing all the mom things, Terry feels like a father already. I'm doing all the dad things, and I don't feel like a father yet. But I think it's coming. When rude people ask adoptive couples who the real parents are, we're supposed to say that the real parents are the people there in the middle of the night, the people the kid comes to when he needs something. And most importantly, the real parents-- the real dad, in this case-- is the person the kid calls dad. The kid turned three months old just before Father's Day. He isn't calling us anything yet, but he will. Soon he'll understand that he has parents, two dads, and he'll come to me and he'll call me dad. And that's when I think I'll finally feel like a father. I hope.
特里追随他父亲的足迹，而我在追随我父亲的足迹。并没有完全与孩子建立联系，没有陪伴那么多，有时在他早上醒来之前离开，晚上在他已经睡着之后回家。做所有的妈妈该做的事，特里感觉自己已经是一个父亲了。我在做所有爸爸该做的事，但我还不感觉像个父亲。但我认为它会来的。当粗鲁的人问领养夫妇谁是真正的父母时，我们应该说真正的父母是那些在半夜里照顾孩子的人，是孩子需要什么时会去找的人。而最重要的是，真正的父母——在这种情况下，真正的父亲——就是孩子称呼为爸爸的那个人。孩子在父亲节前夕刚满三个月。他还没称呼我们任何东西，但他会。很快他就会明白他有父母，有两个爸爸，他会来找我，叫我爸爸。那时我想我终于会感觉像个父亲了。我希望。
Writer Dan Savage in Seattle.
作家丹·萨维奇在西雅图。
Coming up, a father, a daughter, a lie that lasted half a year. Four inch high human beings and how a child can solve parenting problems when parents cannot figure them out on their own. That's all in a minute from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
接下来，一位父亲，一个女儿，一个持续了半年的谎言。四英寸高的人类，以及当父母无法自行解决问题时，孩子如何能解决育儿问题。这一切将在国际公共广播电台的节目继续，一分钟后。
It's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, invite a variety of writers and performers to tackle that theme. Today's program, for Father's Day, we bring you stories about fathers who do not get close to their kids, and about fathers who do, as we listen to them talk with the kids. Lawrence Weschler is an author and journalist, a writer at The New Yorker magazine. And this story is about an odd sort of breach of trust between father and child. A breach of trust done without meaning to and what happened next. He and his 11-year-old daughter, Sara, went into a radio studio in New York City to tell us the story. It begins simply enough, when she was little and he would read to her.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们会选择一个主题，邀请各种作家和表演者来探讨这个主题。今天的节目，为了父亲节，我们为你们带来关于那些并不亲近孩子的父亲的故事，以及关于那些亲近孩子的父亲的故事，我们听他们与孩子交谈。劳伦斯·韦施勒是一位作家和记者，《纽约客》杂志的撰稿人。这个故事是关于父亲和孩子之间一种奇怪的信任违背。一种无意中造成的信任违背，以及接下来发生了什么。他和11岁的女儿萨拉走进纽约市的一个广播演播室，给我们讲了这个故事。它开始得很简单，那时她还小，他会给她读书。
She would get into very active conversations with the characters in the books while we were reading. So, for example, when we were reading Little House on the Prairie, there would be these moments where she would interrupt my reading and say, wait a second, I want to talk to the Indian. And we'd have to go look for a picture of the Indian, and she'd say to the Indian, "Look, Indian, in a few pages you're going to meet Laura. But you've got to be-- understand, I know she's taking your land, but it's not her fault. She's just a kid. Now let me talk to Laura." And we'd go back and we'd talk to Laura. And in these things, I would take on the role of the Indian, and I'd say things like, you know, who's that talking? And so forth. And we would have these incredibly elaborate conversations. Do you remember that, Sara?
我们在读书的时候，她会与书中的人物进行非常活跃的对话。例如，当我们读《大草原上的小木屋》时，会有一些时刻她会打断我的阅读说，“等一下，我想和印第安人说话。”于是我们不得不去找印第安人的图片，她会对印第安人说：“看，印第安人，几页之后你就会遇到劳拉。但你必须——明白，我知道她在占用你的土地，但这不是她的错。她只是个孩子。现在让我和劳拉说话。”然后我们又回去和劳拉说话。在这些事情中，我会扮演印第安人的角色，我会说诸如“是谁在说话？”之类的话。等等。于是我们会有这些极其复杂的对话。你记得吗，萨拉？
Yes.
记得。
Anyway, this sort of thing would go on all the time, and at a later point we began reading The Borrower s series. The series of wonderful books by Mary Noble.
总之，这类事情一直在发生，后来我们开始读《借东西的地下小人》系列。玛丽·诺贝尔的精彩系列书籍。
Norton. Norton.
诺顿。诺顿。
By Mary Norton, that's right. And should Sara describe what the book is about, maybe?
玛丽·诺顿，没错。萨拉，你想描述一下这本书是关于什么的吗？也许？
Sure. Sara, explain what the Borrowers are like.
好的。萨拉，解释一下借东西的小人是什么样的。
Well, the Borrowers-- it's about these little people who are, I think, like four inches tall. And they live under the floorboards in the house. And what they do is they take things from people, little things that they can use around their house.
嗯，借东西的小人——这是关于这些小人，我想，他们大概只有四英寸高。他们住在房子地板下。他们所做的是从人们那里拿东西，他们可以在家里用的小东西。
So what kinds of things do they take?
那么他们拿什么样的东西呢？
Well, they take pocket watches, and stamps, for like pictures on the wall.
嗯，他们拿怀表，和邮票，就像墙上的画一样。
And part of the point about Borrowers is that they're not allowed-- are they allowed to talk to people?
借东西小人的部分要点是他们不被允许——他们被允许和人说话吗？
No.
不。
Do you want to talk about that a little bit?
你想谈谈那个吗？
Well, because they think that people can really hurt them, because according to the book it's happened before.
嗯，因为他们认为人们真的会伤害他们，因为根据书里的内容，这以前发生过。
Right.
没错。
So anyway, we were reading this book. And one day I came home and Sara was incredibly excited. Her face was just glowing, and she said, "Daddy, you won't believe it! We have Borrowers here in our own house!" And my memory is that-- maybe you remember this differently, Sara-- but my memory was that she went to a particular place in the basement and she pointed at this little kind of hole in the wall in the basement, near the floor. And she said, "I was coming down the stairs and there was one of them standing right there, a little girl, and she was wearing a pink taffeta skirt." That's what you said. "And I froze, and she froze, and we looked at each other. And I knew I wasn't supposed to talk to her, and that she shouldn't talk to me, but we just looked at each other. And after about 30 seconds, she kind of waved her hand, just slightly, and she ran away. And it was right there." And Sara took me to the place where it was.
总之，我们在读这本书。有一天我回家，萨拉极其兴奋。她的脸在发光，她说：“爸爸，你不会相信的！我们家里有借东西的小人！”我的记忆是——也许你的记忆不同，萨拉——但我的记忆是她走到地下室的一个特定地方，指着地下室地板附近墙上的一个小洞。她说：“我下楼梯的时候，他们中的一个站在那里，一个小女孩，她穿着粉红色的塔夫绸裙子。”这就是你说的。“我惊呆了，她也惊呆了，我们看着对方。我知道我不应该和她说话，她也不应该和我说话，但我们只是看着对方。大约30秒后，她挥了挥手，轻轻地，然后跑开了。就在那里。”萨拉带我去那个地方。
And Sara, let me just ask you, what do you remember of this?
萨拉，让我问你，你还记得这些吗？
Well, I remember having seen-- well, you see. It's like-- it's sort of strange to say this, because like-- I feel like I'm betraying the Borrowers. But I still believe in them. And like if I ever actually got to meet one, I'd never tell anyone. And I do remember having seen something. And it wasn't really for 30 seconds. It was like for maybe 10 seconds. And then it ran away.
嗯，我记得看到过——嗯，你看。这就像是——说这个很奇怪，因为就像——我感觉我在背叛那些借东西的小人。但我仍然相信他们。如果我真的有机会遇到一个，我永远不会告诉任何人。我确实记得看到过什么东西。那其实不是30秒。就像大概10秒钟。然后它就跑开了。
And even now when you think about it, you can picture-- you can picture seeing--
即使现在当你想到它，你也能想象——你也能想象看到——
Yeah, yeah. I didn't imagine it. It was definitely there.
是的，是的。我没有想象它。它绝对在那里。
And it was a little girl.
而且那是个小女孩。
Yeah, I think.
是的，我想是。
OK.
好的。
And then, over the next few days, Sara began leaving things for this Borrower. And the first thing in the morning she would race downstairs to see whether the things had been picked up.
然后，接下来的几天里，萨拉开始为这个借东西的小人留下东西。每天清晨她都会冲到楼下看那些东西是否被拿走了。
Do you remember what kind of things you left?
你记得你留下了什么东西吗？
I left like-- sometimes I'd leave like toothpicks or pieces of food.
我留下了比如——有时我会留下牙签或食物碎片。
What do they use toothpicks for?
他们用牙签做什么？
Oh, just like to dig with, and you know?
哦，就像用来挖东西，你知道吧？
Kind of an all-purpose tool.
算是万能工具。
Yeah. Walking stick, things like that.
是的。拐杖，类似的东西。
Anyway, so she would leave these things there, and she would be so disappointed. And disappointment verging on desolation that they weren't picked up. And she'd have long conversations with me. She'd say, "You know, why aren't they picking them up? Don't they know that I'm giving it to them?" And I would try to explain that maybe, maybe they were scared or nervous or something. That's how Borrowers are. But she was so sad. And this went on-- I figured this would end-- but at a certain point, this went on for a week. And I don't know why I did it because it began a cascade of consequences. But one night I picked up the stuff and put it in my pocket. And the next morning she came bounding up the stairs saying, "Daddy, you won't believe it! There are Borrowers, just like I said! They took the stuff! They took the stuff!" And she was transported with delight. And I figured that would be the end of it. But it wasn't.
总之，她会把这些东西留在那里，然后她会非常失望。那种失望接近于荒凉，因为它们没被拿走。她会和我进行长时间的对话。她会说：“你知道，为什么他们不拿走它们？他们不知道这是我给他们的吗？”我会试着解释也许，也许他们被吓到了，或者紧张之类的。借东西的小人就是这样。但她太难过了。这持续了——我以为这会结束——但在某一点，这持续了一个星期。我不知道我为什么要那么做，因为它引发了一连串的后果。但有一天晚上我捡起了那些东西，放进了口袋。第二天早上她蹦蹦跳跳地跑上楼梯说：“爸爸，你不会相信的！有借东西的小人，就像我说的那样！他们拿走了东西！他们拿走了东西！”她欣喜若狂。我以为那将是结束。但并没有。
Well, what happened next, Sara?
那么接下来发生了什么，萨拉？
I started writing to them. I started writing letters.
我开始给他们写信。我开始写信。
OK. Why don't I ask you to pull out one of those letters and let's hear what you wrote for the first one.
好的。为什么我不请你拿出其中一封信，让我们听听你第一封信写了什么。
I'll read the first one. OK.
我来读第一封。好的。
Now you were six at the time, right?
你那时六岁，对吧？
Seven. Dear Borrowers, I have seen you but I want to meet you. If I do, I will not tell anyone without your permission. Agreed or not agreed? And then this says, Borrowers--
七岁。亲爱的借东西的小人，我见过你们，但我想见你们。如果我见了，未经你们允许我不会告诉任何人。同意还是不同意？然后这写着，借东西的小人——
Well, then-- just one second. So what happened is that that note, on a little yellow Post-it, lay by the hole for several days. And for several mornings, Sara would be completely devastated that it had not been answered. So I went through several days of not quite knowing what to do, because she was getting more and more sad about this, and more concerned. And so then I figured, well, it won't do any harm to pick up the piece of paper and write a little tiny message back. Which I did.
嗯，然后——等一下。所以发生的事情是那张便条，写在一张黄色便签纸上，放在洞边好几天。几个早晨，萨拉因为没有得到回复而彻底崩溃。所以我经历了几天不知道该怎么办，因为她越来越难过，越来越担心。于是我想，嗯，捡起那张纸，回写一个小小的信息不会有什么坏处。于是我做了。
Do you have that there, as well?
你那里也有那封信吗？
Yeah, it's on the same piece of paper.
是的，就在同一张纸上。
OK, so?
好的，那么？
Dear Sara, gosh, this is strange. Who are you? How do you know about Borrowers? I thought no human beings ever knew about us. My dad says it's too dangerous for Borrowers to meet a human being. And he even says I mustn't write to you. But maybe at least I can write. Will you write back? I hope so. I will keep it a secret from my dad. Signed, Annabellie. P.S., I am 11. How about you?
亲爱的萨拉，天呐，这太奇怪了。你是谁？你是怎么知道借东西小人的？我以为没有人类知道我们的存在。我爸爸说借东西的小人遇见人类太危险了。他甚至说我不准给你写信。但也许至少我可以写信。你会回信吗？我希望如此。我会对我爸爸保密的。签名，安娜贝利。附言，我11岁。你呢？
And so you got this. Do you remember getting this letter?
于是你收到了这个。你记得收到这封信吗？
Mm-hmm.
嗯哼。
Do you remember that morning, what you said when you came up the stairs?
你记得那天早上，当你跑上楼梯时说了什么吗？
No.
不记得。
What did she say? Do you remember?
她说了什么？你记得吗？
Oh, she was just, "They are-- I told you! I told you! And she answered, she answered! And she wants me to write back!" And she was over the moon. And she wrote back immediately.
哦，她只是说：“他们是——我告诉过你！我告诉过你！她回答了，她回答了！她想让我回信！”她高兴坏了。她立刻回信了。
Yeah.
是啊。
So, Ren, did you conceive of your Borrowers as being descendants of the Borrowers in the book?
那么，伦，你把你的借东西的小人构想为书里借东西的小人的后代吗？
Well, it was unclear. I mean, it was a possibility. And it was up to Sara to keep dredging and find out more. And so there-- a large part of the correspondence is Sara doing genealogical work on the family. And asking all kinds of questions.
嗯，这不清楚。我的意思是，这是一种可能性。由萨拉来继续挖掘并找出更多信息。所以那里——大部分通信是萨拉在做家族谱系工作。问各种问题。
Yeah. I would ask like, what was your grandmother's name? And it turned out that her grandmother was Arrietty, which is the main character.
是的。我会问比如，你祖母叫什么名字？结果发现她祖母叫阿里埃蒂，也就是书里的主角。
The main character in the book?
书里的那个主角？
Yeah. And she says that she calls her dad Pea, like as in a peapod. Because in the book the dad is Pod. And then she calls her mom Hommy, because in the book the mother is Homily.
是的。她说她爸爸叫波，就像豌豆荚的那个波。因为书里爸爸叫波德。然后她叫她妈妈霍米，因为书里妈妈叫霍米莉。
How long did the letters go back and forth? How many letters were there?
信件来回了多久？一共有多少封信？
I think there were-- well, there were over 17. Because I didn't finish counting, but I counted up to 17.
我想有——嗯，超过17封。因为我没算完，但我数到17封。
And there came to be a crisis in the midst of all this, which was that we were going to be moving about half a mile, 3/4 of a mile. And she got into a darker and darker mood, and was really, again, almost desolate. And one day she said, "Daddy, we can't move. What about the Borrowers? What's going to happen to them? They'll starve to death! I've been feeding them for weeks. What are we going to do?"
在这期间出现了一个危机，那就是我们要搬家，大概半英里，3/4英里左右。她陷入了一种越来越阴郁的心情，而且真的，又一次，几乎到了荒凉的地步。有一天她说：“爸爸，我们不能搬家。那借东西的小人怎么办？他们会饿死的！我已经喂了他们好几个星期了。我们该怎么办？”
And so what we ended up doing was my dad said, "Well, they can move with us." And then what I did is I made a map of how to get to our house.
于是我们最后做的是我爸爸说：“嗯，他们可以和我们一起搬。”然后我做的是我画了一张怎么去我们新家的地图。
She did this very elaborate map. And Sara said, "But they're not going to be able to do this all in one day." And so what she did is she found-- what did you do?
她做了这张非常复杂的地图。萨拉说：“但他们不可能在一天之内完成这个。”于是她所做的是她找到了——你做了什么？
Well, there's this restaurant called Villa Nova Equals E in Pelham. And there's this kind of like radiator thing on the outside, I don't know exactly what it is. But there was a hole there big enough for a Borrower to get through. And so what I did is I put some cloth in there to make it comfortable. And well, I told them that they could rest there. Because they could probably make the first half of the trip during the first day. And then it was really close to 5th Avenue, which is our busiest street in Pelham. So that when they had to cross 5th Avenue to get to the other part of Pelham, they could do it in the middle of the night.
嗯，在佩勒姆有一家叫Villa Nova Equals E的餐馆。外面有一种类似散热器的东西，我不知道那确切是什么。但那里有个洞，大到足以让借东西的小人钻过去。所以我做的是我在里面放了一些布让它舒适。而且——我告诉他们他们可以在那里休息。因为他们大概能在第一天完成路程的一半。然后那离第五大道很近，那是佩勒姆最繁忙的街道。所以当他们必须穿过第五大道去佩勒姆的另一部分时，他们可以在半夜进行。
Why would that be important?
为什么那很重要？
Because the cars wouldn't be going back and forth.
因为车不会来回走。
It was going to take them like an hour to get across the street.
穿过街道要花他们大约一个小时。
Not an hour. Like 15 minutes.
不是一个小时。大概15分钟。
OK, excuse me. So suddenly the whole project of moving went from being a near disaster to being a delight. And every time we moved Sara would run downstairs to see whether they had, in fact, brought some of their stuff over, because they had to do it in several different trips, right?
好的，不好意思。所以突然搬家的整个工程从接近灾难变成了一种乐趣。每次我们搬家，萨拉都会冲到楼下看他们是否确实把一些东西搬过来了，因为他们必须分几次搬，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
And each time, it would turn out that they had brought some stuff over, right?
每次，结果都是他们确实搬了一些东西过来，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Parenthetically, it was fairly easy to know what they had because it had all been in my pockets, as I'd been picking it up over the many months of the correspondence. I had a whole shoebox full of stuff that Sara had been leaving for the Borrowers, so I just kind of transported little sprinklings of it each time we moved some of our stuff over.
顺便说一句，很容易知道他们有什么，因为它们一直都在我的口袋里，就像我在几个月的通信中一直捡起来的那样。我有一个装满萨拉留给借东西小人的东西的鞋盒，所以我每次搬我们的一些东西过去时，就撒一点点过去。
And Ren, during this time, were you frightened about where this was all going to lead? That at some point you would get found out?
伦，在这段时间里，你害怕这一切会导向哪里吗？在某一点你会东窗事发？
Well, it was getting strange and actually kind of nerve-wracking. And I would do things like-- I kept on figuring that Sara was going to grow out of this. Or that Sara would associate-- would make the association that this was kind of like what we used to do when I would read about the Indian, or about Laura. I kept on thinking that she would just kind of enjoy that. But she was getting more and more into it. And it was becoming more and more involved. And the more involved, the more I could see how invested Sara was in it. I mean, it really was the main thing going on in her life during that season. And as she began telling friends about it and so forth, the stories had to get more and more elaborate to include all the stray bits of details that were seeping into things. And I didn't quite know where it was going to go. I would do things. I would send the Borrowers on vacations.
嗯，这变得很奇怪，实际上让人心烦意乱。我会做一些事情比如——我一直以为萨拉会长大不再相信这些。或者萨拉会联想到——会把这与我给她读关于印第安人，或关于劳拉的故事时所做的事情联系起来。我一直以为她会只是那种享受。但她越来越深入其中。它变得越来越复杂。越复杂，我就越能看到萨拉投入了多少。我的意思是，那真的是在那段时间里她生活中发生的主要事情。当她开始告诉朋友们等等的时候，故事不得不变得越来越复杂，以包含所有渗入其中的细枝末节。我不知道它会走向何方。我会做一些事情。我会让借东西的小人去度假。
You would send them on vacations?
你让它们去度假？
I would send them-- I would just have them suddenly disappear for a while. And they'd be gone for a while. And I would hope that by the time it was over, Sara would have forgotten. But on the day-- you know, I'd say they'd be gone three weeks. Three weeks later on that day there'd be a note for them from Sara. I'd send them into the woods. There was a little park nearby and for them this was a huge national park. And there was a stream and this was the equivalent of the Mississippi for them. And I would send them off and hoping that Sara would get over it, would move on.
我会让它们突然消失一段时间。它们会消失一段时间。我希望到结束的时候，萨拉已经忘记了。但在那天——你知道，我说它们会离开三个星期。三周后在那天会有萨拉给它们的一张便条。我会让它们进入树林。附近有一个小公园，对它们来说这是一个巨大的国家公园。有一条溪流，这对它们来说相当于密西西比河。我会让它们离开，希望萨拉能克服它，能继续前进。
And Sara, did you suspect at that point?
萨拉，那时你怀疑了吗？
No, no, I--
没有，不，我——
But what was really funny, Sara, is that you would say things sometimes like, "Daddy, it's really weird. Annabellie uses the same kind of pen as you do." And then you'd say, "Yeah, I guess she must have stolen one of your pens." And then one day I heard her talking to her friend, Megan. She said, "Annabellie's handwriting is just like my dad's, only really tiny." She would say things like this and yet not put it together.
但非常有趣的是，萨拉，有时你会说诸如“爸爸，这真的很奇怪。安娜贝利用的钢笔和你的一模一样。”然后你会说：“是的，我猜她一定偷了你的一支钢笔。”然后有一天我听到你和你朋友梅根说话。她说：“安娜贝利的笔迹和我的爸爸的一模一样，只是非常细小。”她会说这类话，但并没有联想到一起。
I really hadn't-- like, the second I suspected it, I was almost sure that it had been him. And I just went up and asked him if it was him.
我真的没有——就像，我怀疑它的那一秒，我几乎确定那是我爸爸。我直接走过去问他是不是他。
Why is it that you started to suspect? Do you remember what happened that made you suspect?
你为什么开始怀疑？你记得发生了什么让你怀疑吗？
I think it was sort of the fact-- not his handwriting, actually. It was that I would tell my dad, for instance, that I was in the basement and I stuck my finger into this hole and I felt something sort of like silky or something. It was probably just some like old piece of cloth that was stuck there. But I felt it and I told my dad-- and it sort of slipped away from my finger. I told my dad about it. And then in the next letter, I'd hear-- Annabellie would be saying, oh, I think that-- was that you who touched me when I was wearing my silk dress? And so I started to think, like I tell my dad things that sometimes I'd exaggerate a little bit. Because when I was younger I exaggerated some things. I made things a little bit more exciting than they might have really been. And then like I read the letter and it had that exaggerated part in it. And so I'd say, like, well, that didn't really happen. I was just like sort of adding that to my story. And so that's--
我想这大概是事实——不是他的笔迹，实际上。是我会告诉爸爸，例如，我在地下室，我把手指伸进这个洞里，感觉到某种像丝绸一样的东西。那可能只是里面卡着的一块旧布。但我感觉到了，我告诉了爸爸——它从我手指上溜走了。我告诉了爸爸。然后在下一封信里，我会听到——安娜贝利会说，哦，我想那——那是你触碰我的时候，我穿着我的丝绸裙子吗？所以我开始想，就像我告诉爸爸的事情，有时我会夸大一点点。因为我小的时候夸大了一些事情。我让事情变得比实际可能的样子更令人兴奋一些。然后就像我读了那封信，它包含了那个夸大的部分。所以我说，嗯，那并没有真正发生。我只是把它加到我的故事里。所以那是——
That made you suspicious.
这让你怀疑。
Yeah, and I asked my dad--
是的，我问了我爸爸——
So what happened there was, We had moved to the new house. We'd been there for a couple months at that point. And I was down in the basement moving some boxes around. And Sara came down there and--
所以发生的事情是，我们搬到了新家。那时我们已经在那里待了几个月了。我在地下室搬一些箱子。萨拉下来了，然后——
And how old--
那时候多大——
She's now eight.
她现在八岁。
In this story?
在这个故事里？
At this point in the story, yeah. And she-- and she began looking-- her lips were trembling. Her lower lip was trembling. And she looked at me very firmly as she is quite capable of doing. And she said, "Daddy, I'm going to ask you a question now. And you have to tell the truth because it's a sin for daddies to lie to their daughters." And my heart just sank. And she said, "Daddy, are you the one who's been writing Annabellie's notes?" And I looked at her, and she looked at me, and there was like silence for five or six seconds. And then I said, "Um, it's kind of complicated, can we talk?" And she said, "Daddy, it's not complicated. It's simple. Are you the one?" And I said, "Well, can we talk about it later?" She said, "No, just tell me. Are you the one or not?" And I took a big breath and I said, "Yes, it is me." And she broke into--
在故事的这一点，是的。她——她开始看——她的嘴唇在颤抖。她的下唇在颤抖。她非常坚定地看着我，就像她完全有能力做到的那样。她说：“爸爸，我现在要问你一个问题。你必须说实话，因为爸爸对女儿撒谎是罪过。”我的心沉了下去。她说：“爸爸，是你一直在写安娜贝利的便条吗？”我看着她，她看着我，沉默了五六秒钟。然后我说：“嗯，这有点复杂，我们可以谈谈吗？”她说：“爸爸，这不复杂。很简单。是你吗？”我说：“嗯，我们可以晚点谈吗？”她说：“不，告诉我。是你还是不是？”我深吸了一口气说：“是的，是我。”她爆发了——
I was crying.
我在哭。
Oh god, she was sobbing.
哦天呐，她在啜泣。
I was so sad.
我太难过了。
She started sobbing. It was easily the most wrenching thing that had happened in my parenthood up to that point. I mean, I had totally blown it. I just felt like a total disaster. And I was crying and she was crying. And you know, we were both kind of clutching each other and holding each other. And we were really in a trap there. We were down the hole at that point. We were in big trouble. And suddenly this kind of calm came over Sara's face. It was kind of like the sun rising in the morning. And her forehead stopped being furrowed, it became smooth. And she just looked at me and she said, "Daddy, don't you realize? You ruined everything. Because there are Borrowers! And you were taking the letters before they were able to get them." And it was a way of-- she had solved everything there. Because among other things, that was what she was going to be able to tell her friends. And they could all chortle about what kind of a crazy father she had. And it was amazing. She found a way of getting us out of this disaster that I suppose I had fashioned for us.
她开始啜泣。那无疑是我为人父母以来发生的最令人揪心的事。我的意思是，我彻底搞砸了。我感觉自己简直是一场彻底的灾难。我在哭，她也在哭。你知道，我们两个都在拥抱对方，抓着对方。我们真的陷进坑里了。我们在那个洞里。我们遇到了大麻烦。突然，一种平静降临在萨拉的脸上。那就像早晨升起的太阳。她的额头不再紧皱，变得平滑。她只是看着我说：“爸爸，你没意识到吗？你毁了一切。因为借东西的小人是存在的！而你在他们拿到信之前就把信拿走了。”这是一种——她解决了一切。因为除此之外，这就是她以后能告诉朋友们的事情。她们都能嘲笑她有一个多么疯狂的父亲。真是太神奇了。她找到了一种让我们摆脱这场灾难的方法，而我猜那是我为我们造成的。
Because I remember saying that you should have left it there. Maybe they would have really written back. You shouldn't have done it because maybe they would have actually written back to me finally at some point. Like I said earlier, I still believe in them. And I know that might sound really babyish to some kids who might listen to this. But I still believe in them. And when I told Megan, my friend, when I told Megan that it had been my dad, she stopped believing in them. And she was just like, whenever I'd talk about it from them on, she'd laugh at me and tell me, "Oh, Sara, stop being a baby." Because she's a year older then me, so she-- at that time, she still considered herself really superior to me, even though we're best friends. And she said, "Oh, Sara, stop being a baby. It's not true. It's just not true." And I said, "But I've seen them." And she said, "No, you haven't. You just imagined it. And it's not true. And you can just stop imagining it and stop telling me about it because it's not true."
因为我记得我说过你应该把它留在那里。也许他们真的会回信。你不该那样做，因为也许他们最终真的会给我回信。就像我之前说的，我仍然相信他们。我知道这对一些听这个节目的孩子来说可能听起来很幼稚。但我仍然相信他们。当我告诉梅根，我的朋友，当我告诉梅根那是我爸爸时，她不再相信他们了。她只是——无论此后我什么时候提到，她都会嘲笑我，告诉我，“哦，萨拉，别那么幼稚。”因为她比我大一岁，所以她——那时，她仍然认为自己在各方面都优于我，即使我们是最好的朋友。她说：“哦，萨拉，别那么幼稚。这不是真的。这根本不是真的。”我说：“但我见过他们。”她说：“不，你没见过。你只是想象出来的。这不是真的。你可以停止想象，别再告诉我这些了，因为它不是真的。”
How do you feel about it now when you look at those letters?
现在当你看着那些信件时，你感觉如何？
I don't know. Like sometimes when I read them, I still sort of can think that, you know, I wonder why this happened to her? I wonder why that happened to her? I wonder why she would say that? Even though I know that it was my dad writing to me, I still sometimes sort of think of there being an Annabellie somewhere out there.
我不知道。就像有时当我读它们时，我仍然会想，你知道，我想知道为什么这发生在她身上？我想知道为什么那发生在她身上？我想知道为什么她会那样说？即使我知道是我爸爸写给我的，我有时仍然会想在外面某个地方真的有一个安娜贝利。
When we pulled out the box last night, of letters, did it bring you pleasure to look at those letters? Did you--
当我们昨晚拿出那箱信时，看那些信给你带来了快乐吗？你是否——
Well, actually I look at it a lot.
嗯，实际上我经常看。
You do?
你经常看？
You look at it a lot?
你经常看吗？
Yeah.
是的。
And what do you think when you look at it?
当你看着它时你在想什么？
Well, I just think it was sort of-- now looking back, it was sort of nice of him to do. Because I remember, when it was happening, and after I'd figured out that it was him, I had asked him, well, can we still sort of write to each other? We never really actually wrote to each other after that, but I just sort of thought after a while that it was a nice thing. And that even though maybe there was no Borrower writing to me, there was maybe-- having my dad make up this whole family was maybe just as special, or maybe almost as special as having actually been writing to a Borrower.
嗯，我只是觉得这——现在回想起来，他能这样做真是太好了。因为我记得，当它发生的时候，在我发现那是他之后，我问过他，嗯，我们还能保持写信吗？我们在那之后再没真正写过信，但我过了一段时间就觉得那是一件好事。即使也许没有借东西的小人给我写信，我也觉得——让我爸爸编造这一整套家族故事也许同样特别，或者几乎和真的给借东西的小人写信一样特别。
Sara, can I ask you, what do you think the lesson of this story is? That is, if parents hear you tell this story, you and your dad tell this story on the radio, and if another parent gets into this kind of situation, what's your advice for them? Should they go along with it? Should they write letters and should they pick up stuff?
萨拉，可以问你，你认为这个故事的教训是什么吗？也就是说，如果父母听到你讲这个故事，你和你爸爸在广播里讲这个故事，如果另一个父母陷入这种境地，你对他们的建议是什么？他们应该配合吗？他们应该写信吗？他们应该捡起东西吗？
I don't know. Because like it was really fun for me to have this kind of experience. But when I found out that it was my dad writing, it was really upsetting. And so I just don't know. I think that if I were a parent and I had that kind of thing, I would not pick it up.
我不知道。因为就像这种经历对我来说真的很有趣。但当我发现是我爸爸写的时，那真的很令人沮丧。所以我只是不知道。我想如果我是父母，我有那种事情，我不会捡起它。
You would not?
你不会？
No, I would keep encouraging my kid, my child, to keep on writing to the Borrowers and trying to get them to write back, but I wouldn't pick it up.
不，我会继续鼓励我的孩子，我的孩子，继续给借东西的小人写信，并试图让他们回信，但我不会捡起它。
What if they keep coming to you, so sad every morning, the way you were sad coming to me, and just pleading, I wish, I wish, I wish they would come. Can you imagine ever picking it up?
如果他们一直来找你，每天早上都那么难过，就像你当初难过地来找我，只是哀求着，我希望，我希望，我希望他们能来。你能想象捡起它吗？
No.
不。
Really?
真的吗？
It's just-- I don't think it's fair to lead someone on like that.
这只是——我不认为那样误导某人是公平的。
Ren, as far as you're concerned, what's the lesson of the story? If you had this to do again, if you would get into this situation again, or if you could go back with the benefit of hindsight, what would you do? Would you have left the letters?
伦，就你而言，故事的教训是什么？如果让你重做一遍，如果你再次陷入这种情况，或者如果你能带着后见之明回去，你会怎么做？你会留下那些信吗？
I mean, I'd like to say that had I to live it over again I wouldn't do it this way, but I'm not sure. Because it started so naturally. And in the end, by the, way, what I'd have to say is probably the most poignant, closest, amazing moment I've had as a single-- you know, the moment I'll remember of a particular phase in my life, is the holding onto each other in the basement, both of us crying. But Sara not running away, and Sara saving us. And that kind of cemented our relationship in a really kind of wonderful way. So I mean, I don't--
我的意思是，我想说如果能重活一次我不会这样做，但我不能确定。因为它开始得太自然了。而且最后，顺便说一下，我要说的是，这可能是我作为一个单亲——你知道，我会在我生命中某个阶段记住的那个时刻，是最感人、最亲密、最神奇的时刻，就是我们在地下室紧紧抓住对方，我们两个都在哭。但萨拉没有跑开，萨拉拯救了我们。这确实以一种非常奇妙的方式巩固了我们的关系。所以我认为，我不会——
It might not end that way for everybody.
这对每个人来说可能不会以那种方式结束。
Yeah, it might not end that way for everybody, that's true. I continue to puzzle about it. And it is unresolved for me as my answer is indicating, I suppose.
是的，那可能不会对每个人都以那种方式结束，这是真的。我继续对此感到困惑。这对我来说悬而未决，正如我的回答所表明的那样，我想。
It's interesting to me that the way that you view the lesson of the story is that Sara saved the two of you, that as a parent you got yourself into a moment where you literally didn't know what to do. And that she finally said the thing that made everything OK.
有趣的是，你认为这个故事的教训是萨拉拯救了你们两个，作为父母你让自己陷入了一个你真的不知道该怎么办的时刻。而她最终说了那句让一切变得没关系的话。
Yeah, I absolutely feel that. Has it affected our relationship, do you think? Do you not trust me in a way you used to trust me?
是的，我绝对这样感觉。你认为它影响了我们的关系吗？你是否不再像过去那样信任我了？
No, no, no. I still trust you.
不，不，不。我仍然信任你。
Sara, do you view this as one of the moments when you were closest to your dad?
萨拉，你认为这是你与爸爸最亲近的时刻之一吗？
Well, I'm very close to my dad. So I don't know. Yeah, I guess so. But it's not like much closer than I am usually. Because I'm very close to my dad like all the time. But yeah, it is one of the times that I was closest, I guess. Yeah.
嗯，我和我爸爸很亲近。所以我不知道。是的，我想是吧。但那并不是比我平时亲近得多。因为我总是和我爸爸很亲近。但是的，这是我最亲近的时刻之一，我想。是的。
So my heart is in my throat.
我的心都要跳出来了。
Hey, Sara, if you still think they exist, have you tried to spot them? Have you tried to wait for them and spot them again?
嘿，萨拉，如果你仍然认为他们存在，你试过发现他们吗？你试过等待他们并再次发现他们吗？
Well, I have seen-- well, I'm not sure, because I've seen them in the shadows. The only time I'm absolutely positive I saw one was downstairs in the basement of my old house. But I have seen them since. Sometimes I'll go and I'll sit at the basement steps and look around. And sometimes I'll be making, let's say, a cake. And I'll leave a little bit of dough wrapped in some paper by the staircase, at the basement, in the basement, for them to take.
嗯，我已经见过——嗯，我不确定，因为我在阴影中见过他们。我绝对确信我见过一个的唯一一次是在我老房子的地下室里。但我从那以后见过他们。有时我会去坐在地下室的楼梯上四处看看。有时我会做，比如，一个蛋糕。我会留下一点包在纸里的生面团在楼梯旁，在地下室里，供他们拿走。
And do they take it?
他们拿走了吗？
Well, I don't know. Because I don't find it, but then again, who knows what that might be. It could be--
嗯，我不知道。因为我没发现它，但话又说回来，谁知道那可能是什么。它可能是——
Right. It could be bugs.
没错。可能是虫子。
Mouse. Dad.
老鼠。爸爸。
A mouse or a dad. This child is afflicted.
一只老鼠或一个爸爸。这孩子受到了折磨。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
The house is crawling with them.
房子里到处都是他们。
Lawrence Weschler is the author of Mr. Wilson's Cabinet of Wonders and Calamities of Exile . Sara Weschler just graduated from elementary school this week. When we spoke she said that she would be listening to our radio program this weekend in the car.
劳伦斯·韦施勒是《威尔逊先生的奇迹陈列室》和《流亡的灾难》的作者。萨拉·韦施勒这周刚刚从小学毕业。当我们交谈时，她说她这周末会在车里听我们的广播节目。
I don't want us to listen to it at the house. Because if there are still Borrowers in our house, I don't want them to hear that and think that they can't trust me. Because it's right now, I'm like telling their whole story. So I feel like I'm sort of betraying them, you know? And I just like wanted to make sure that they knew that, you know, if I actually did meet one, I wouldn't tell anyone. I would never tell a single person in the world.
我不想我们在家里听它。因为如果我们的房子里还有借东西的小人，我不想让他们听到这个，认为他们不能信任我。因为就在现在，我就像在讲他们整个故事。所以我感觉我是在背叛他们，你知道吗？我只是想确保他们知道，你知道，如果我真的遇到了一个，我不会告诉任何人。我永远不会告诉这世上的任何一个人。
Well, the program was produced today by Nancy Updike and myself with Alix Spiegel and Julie Snyder. Senior editor, Paul Tough. Contributing editors, Jack Hitt, Margy Rochlin and consigli Sarah Vowell. Production help from Laura Doggett, Sylvia Lemus and [? Sayuni ?] [? Davenport. ?] Thanks today to Street Level Youth Media.
好了，节目今天由南希·厄普代克和我，以及阿利克斯·斯皮格尔和朱莉·斯奈德制作。资深编辑，保罗·塔夫。特约编辑，杰克·希特，玛吉·罗克林和顾问萨拉·沃威尔。制作协助来自劳拉·多格特，西尔维娅·莱姆斯和[？萨尤尼？][？达文波特？]。感谢今天来自街头青年媒体。
Happy Father's Day to my own dad, Barry Glass, in Baltimore. If you want to buy a cassette of this program, call us at WBEZ here in Chicago. 312-832-3380. 312-832-3380. Our email address, [email protected] . Or you can listen to any of our programs over the internet for free-- for free-- at our website. www.thislife.org. That's thislife, one word, no space in it.
父亲节快乐，给我自己的爸爸，巴里·格拉斯，在巴尔的摩。如果你想购买这个节目的磁带，请拨打我们这里芝加哥WBEZ的电话。312-832-3380。312-832-3380。我们的电子邮件地址是 [email protected] 。或者你可以在互联网上免费——免费——在我们的网站上收听我们的任何节目。www.thislife.org。也就是thislife，一个词，中间没有空格。
This week, you'll also find at our website some of Sara's Weschler's correspondence with the Borrowers, right there.
本周，你还会在我们的网站上找到一些萨拉·韦施勒与借东西的小人的通信，就在那里。
Well, This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
Also from Double Take magazine. If you enjoy This American Life , you may also like Double Take . Documenting everyday life through reporting, fiction, photography, and poetry. For your own sample copy, that's your very own, you can keep it forever, the toll free number is 1-877-4DOUBLE.
也来自《Double Take》杂志。如果你喜欢《美国生活》，你可能也会喜欢《Double Take》。通过报道、小说、摄影和诗歌记录日常生活。如需你自己的样本，就是你真正拥有的，你可以永远保留它，免费电话号码是1-877-4DOUBLE。
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who we have a plan for. I have to say a big, big plan.
WBEZ管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，我们有一个计划。我必须说一个大大的计划。
Put him in leather diapers, teach him to dance to YMCA, and slowly draw him into our perverted lifestyle.
给他穿上皮革尿布，教他随着《YMCA》跳舞，并慢慢将他引入我们那变态的生活方式。
Indeed, we will. Well, I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
确实，我们会这样做。好了，我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
PRI，国际公共广播电台。